Meet Trevor Hawthorn, now known as D-4651.
On the outside, he was an armed robber who
murdered two people during a convenience store
shoot-out in Texas.
But now, since being condemned to death, he’s
been picked up for D-Class testing by the
SCP Foundation.
Now also meet Junior Researcher Dr. Julia
Reed - an aspiring Foundation scientist with
an undiagnosed heart condition.
The kind of heart condition that doesn’t
mix well with a high-pressure job at The SCP
Foundation.
These two woke up on the morning of December
6th, 2011, completely unaware of the fact
they were only hours away from causing one
of the most devastating containment breaches
Site 19 had seen in years.
Many people died that day, but thankfully
for everyone else, SCP-131 were there to save
the day.
When you think of a hero, you probably don’t
picture a pair of little cyborgs with one
eye and the intelligence of a household cat,
but this is the tale of how two of the most
unassuming anomalies at Site 19 managed to
save thousands of people from two of the Site’s
most dangerous inmates.
Open your eyes, and keep them open.
If you so much as blink, it’s all over for
you.
How long can you hold it?
Difficult, right?
Now imagine you’re having a staring contest
with an entity that can kill you if you dare
to blink for even a fraction of a second.
Or, even worse, a creature that could potentially
kill hundreds or even thousands of people
if your attention drifts from it for any amount
of time.
Try keeping your eyes open with that kind
of crushing pressure.
We’re talking about two of the most deadly
Euclid and Keter Class anomalies out there
- SCP-173, the Killer Sculpture, a violent
Euclid-class entity that is incapable of moving
while being looked at.
If ever it’s unobserved, it’ll snap the
neck of anyone nearby.
SCP-689, known as Haunter in the Dark, is
an equally dangerous and even more attention
demanding statue.
These two entities are beyond dangerous - even
SCP-682 is terrified of the Killer Sculpture,
and researchers have been considering the
use of 689 to potentially eliminate the hard-to-destroy
reptile for quite some time.
Their greatest concern though, is whether
the 30-centimeter-tall statue would cause
too much collateral damage to Foundation personnel
in the process.
Trevor Hawthorn was part of the three-man
D-class detail meant to clean out SCP-173’s
containment chamber at regular intervals.
While on cleaning duty, two D-Classes can
keep staring at the Sculpture while the other
tidies up the cell, alternating turns to blink.
But that morning, Trevor had woken up in his
containment cell with a killer migraine, and
soon, that migraine would be killing far more
than just him.
The containment procedures in 689’s cell
were also a three person job.
689 is a small, green soapstone statue of
a skeletal being sitting on a throne, believed
to be some form of underworld death deity
discovered by German archaeologists in India.
This is a work of religious art that demands
your attention, or you and anyone else who’s
ever seen this Keter-class nightmare will
suffer a horrifying fate.
Anyone who’s ever seen the statue is “infected”
by its anomalous effects.
It must be observed constantly, or someone
who’s seen it in the past will suddenly
drop dead of a severe health issue like a
stroke or multiple rupturing organs.
Like the God of Death the statue represents,
it appears on top of the dead body of whoever
it just killed.
If not continually paid attention to, it’ll
keep hopping from person to person until it’s
killed everyone who’s ever looked at it.
Its teleporting abilities, and the fact that
it poses a threat to so many, make this a
truly formidable foe.
It’s kept in a constantly-lit cell, and
is observed by two members of D-Class personnel
at all times.
But a crucial third party in the containment
of SCP - 689 is a member of personnel at Level
2 or above.
They remain in a control room, wearing a special
visor to prevent them from ever seeing 689
and becoming infected themselves.
If the containment fails, it’s their job
to throw the kill switch on the D-Class observers
to prevent them from becoming vectors for
infection.
Today, this job fell on Dr. Julia Reed.
She was linked to the two observers via an
audio feed, allowing her to remain in constant
contact with them, and she had her finger
on the activation key for a pair of explosive
collars that were around the D-Class’ necks.
Little did they know, Dr. Reed’s heart was
its own time bomb.
Now you know what we’re up against: A snap-happy
Sculpture, and a teleporting death statue
with a hit list containing everyone who’s
ever glanced at it.
What can SCP - 131 bring to the table?
The two small, cycloptic anomalies have only
one remarkable ability: They never blink.
That and a soft spot for humans.
These Safe-Class SCPs pose no threat to their
handlers, and can even form attachments to
researchers and other staff who show affection
towards them.
Of course, forming these bonds is discouraged
by Site 19’s Director because it can be
distracting, but that doesn’t mean it doesn’t
happen.
The two Eye Pods, known as SCP-131-A and SCP-131-B,
are identical in appearance except for their
colors.
A is burnt orange, and B is mustard yellow.
The two of them appear to communicate with
one another via high-pitched squeaking noises,
and also seem to have an innate ability to
detect danger occurring in the vicinity, as
well as danger occurring near individuals
they’ve bonded with.
Because of their inability to cause harm and
their generally affectionate demeanor, the
Eye Pods are allowed to roam around Site 19,
provided they keep out of the way of researchers
and stay out of restricted areas.
They seem to pretty much stick to the rules,
though check-ins on A and B are required every
hour, just to be safe.
As the Eye Pods were moving freely around
the facility, Trevor and another D-Class maintained
a visual on the Sculpture in its containment
chamber while a third man swept up the mixture
of blood and excrement staining the concrete
floors.
Things were going fine, until Trevor’s migraine
got the better of him.
A sudden flash of intense pain shot through
his head, and in a moment of weakness he made
a terrible mistake.
With an audible groan of pain, Trevor closed
his eyes and forced his fingers to his temples.
The groan had taken his fellow observer off
guard, and the man’s eyes flitted over to
him for a fraction of a second.
But a fraction of a second is all the Sculpture
needs.
In an instant, Trevor and his fellow watcher
had their necks snapped, and the third D-Class
was murdered before he even had the chance
to turn around.
Containment protocol dictates that the door
is to be sealed behind the cleaning crew while
they’re working with 173, but this time,
perhaps due to complacency, the guards had
neglected to reinforce the door.
They got their heads twisted a hundred and
eighty degrees for their trouble.
SCP-173 was loose.
Mobile Task Forces were dispatched to aid
in the re-containment effort as 173 began
wreaking havoc around the facility, but things
were about to get even worse.
It seemed like business as usual over at the
containment cell of SCP-689.
Two D-Classes observed while Dr. Reed dictated
to them over an earpiece from her control
center.
However, what Dr. Reed thought were just minor
chest pains was actually the onset of heart
failure.
When the two D-Classes heard their supervisor
experiencing a fatal heart attack on the other
end of the line, they began to panic.
This meant their attention wasn’t entirely
on SCP-689, and they were further distracted
by the chaos SCP - 173 was causing elsewhere
in the facility: murdering researchers, guards,
and maintenance workers alike which led to
power outages.
The lights in 689’s containment cell shut
down.
Guards were dispatched to execute the observers,
as is protocol for 689 containment breaches,
but the fact that resources were already stretched
thin by the 173 breach caused a fatal error
in judgment from a guard posted nearby.
In a panic, he opened the door to find one
D-Class dead with the statue perched on his
body and the other one running straight for
him in blind fear.
The two collided and tumbled out into the
hall.
Both were now infected by 689’s anomalous
attention, and both were now doomed.
Moments later, the two of them were dead,
the statue perched on their bodies, accidentally
catching the eye of several researchers and
guards running to deal with the 173 situation.
For these two deadly anomalies, it was becoming
an all-you-can-kill buffet.
The staff of Site 19 were now dealing with
one anomaly that needed to be looked at constantly,
and another that if you even glance at it,
you are effectively infected with a fatal
disease.
The Eye Pods, sensing an imminent danger nearby,
immediately sprung into action.
It would be up to these cute, harmless anomalies
to save the terrified staff during this chaotic
double-containment breach.
In a nearby hallway, a fleeing Foundation
researcher heard the crunches of her colleagues’
necks breaking behind her.
173 was getting closer.
This thing couldn’t be outrun.
She turned, and saw the statue standing there,
just ten feet away from her, a dead researcher
laying on the ground in front of it.
She was locked in a deadly staring contest
with The Sculpture.
How long she could survive was now dependent
on how long she could keep her eyes open,
and it was getting harder by the second.
She could feel her eyes drying.
They burned under the ceiling lights.
173 just waited.
This wasn’t a contest she could win.
In a final moment of terror, the researcher
was forced to finally close her eyes and she
waited for the crunch.
But it never came.
Instead, she heard familiar high pitched squeaking
noises.
She opened her eyes, crying tears of relief,
as she saw SCP-131-A sitting behind 173, watching
it with its constant, unblinking gaze.
The Killer Sculpture was paralyzed by a cheerful
little Safe-Class anomaly.
Across the facility, a similar situation had
unfolded with SCP-689.
The statue of death had claimed many lives,
but SCP-131-B had swooped in and frozen the
statue in place with its never ending gaze.
Soon after, a Mobile Task Force with vision-blocking
visors used advanced echo-location technology
to collect SCP-689 and return it to its containment
cell.
Everyone who’d seen the anomaly was, as
standard protocol dictates, gathered up for
later termination.
Meanwhile, a Mobile Task Force returned the
paralyzed 173 back to its containment cell
with a forklift.
No containment breach is ever a picnic, containment
breaches with multiple dangerous anomalies
are even less so, but the heroic role that
SCP-131 played in bringing things back under
control was indispensable.
After all, it’s not just raw power that
counts when it comes to anomalies.
The only anomalous power 131 needed to save
the entire site was its ability to keep looking
when nobody else could.
They’re so effective in this role that they’ve
been seriously considered for permanent roles
as “wardens” for SCPs like 173 and 689.
And in our opinion, they’re more than qualified.
Now check out “SCP - 999 - The Tickle Monster”
and “SCP - 5031 - Yet Another Murder Monster”
for more surprisingly wholesome anomalies
under the care of the SCP Foundation!